derrière le dynamisme économique et la
parente opulence de la zone frontalière
il y à une précarité qui touche de plus
en plus de familles et les chiffres
avancés par la croix-rouge de pontarlier
sont éloquents il y a eu cette année par
exemple trois fois plus de bénéficiaires
de l'aide alimentaire
en fait ce sont maintenant des centaines
de foyers qui sont aidées par
l'association
il ya d'une part le fait qu'on a ouvert
d'autres tournées dire qu'on était
actuellement sur six points de
distribution et que lorsque avait
demande des services sociaux on a on a
ouvert le point de distribution de
morteau on a ouvert un point de
distribution un jaune
alain perron à eaubonne en plus la crise
de la pandémie a fait que bayeux plus de
besoin avec ces véhicules et grâce à ses
bénévoles la croix rouge se déplace donc
de village en village souvent en
partenariat avec d'autres structures
ce sera encore le cas demain puisque
l'association va distribuer à un repas
de réveillon aux familles dans le besoin
les bénévoles vont chez les gens qui se
sont inscrits et parce qu'il ya une
inscription au préalable et on est déçus
lui adresse directe en zone urbaine des
restaurants du coeur
nous on se déplace surtout parce que
pour les gens qui n'ont pas de moyen de
locomotion personnes âgées qui peuvent
pas se déplacer gens qui sont dans la
précarité qui n'ont pas de véhicule
donc on pourvoi au justement au manque
qui peut y avoir par rapport aux
restaurants du coeur et autres
associations et parce que la mobilité
donc un enjeu social la croix-rouge de
pontarlier veut dès l'année prochaine
développer un réseau de covoiturage